Germany is not only a very wealthy country,
it's also a country famous for running like
clockwork and for producing things of very
high quality.
[That at least is the reputation, if it’s
German, it's good].
The fact is that over recent decades Germany
experienced one of the most significant economic
miracles in history.
We have already told you about it both here
on VisualPolitik and on our sister channel
VisualEconomik.
Today, Germany is synonymous with high productivity,
thriving companies and highly skilled workers.
However, it has one problem, a potentially
very serious problem that we have not yet
told you about: its inability to attract skilled
labor.
Have you ever considered going to work in
Germany?
I'm sure many of you have, but I'm sure many
more of you have thought about the UK, the
Netherlands, Canada, Australia or the US first.
Despite being a very rich country, with many
jobs and what appears to be the opportunity
to build great careers, Germany does not seem
to be an attractive place for highly skilled
workers.
It ranks much worse than the rest of its comparable
countries.
It does not reach the extreme of Japan...
But it is an anomaly.
An anomaly that would always be a problem,
but even more so when your working-age population
is shrinking.
So the question is, why on earth is Germany
such an unattractive destination for highly
qualified foreigners?
What could this mean for what has traditionally
been considered the driver of Europe?
What is the government doing to remedy this
situation?
Well, in this video we are going to answer
all these questions.
And who knows, maybe by the end of it you
will consider moving there...
Or maybe not.
Let's get started.
VisualPolitik viewers, Germany is a top 10
country.
And by that I mean that it is almost always
among the top 10 countries when we look at
practically any index of well-being and development:
GDP per capita, education levels, productivity
levels, access to basic services, etc., etcetera.
But its state-of-the-art factories, its modern
educational classrooms and its more than enviable
annual investment in techno-industrial development
would be meaningless if there were no teachers,
engineers, doctors, workers and professionals
to put this immense productive apparatus into
operation.
And the problem...
We can start to see the problem perfectly
in this graph:
According to official UN figures, the German
population will start to shrink as of 2023.
From a total population of around 83 million
people that it has at present, the forecast
is for the 80 million mark to be breached
by 2047 and to dip into the 70 millions by
the last decade of this century.
It is not as dramatic a contraction as is
expected in countries such as Japan or South
Korea, but it is still economically relevant.
This data basically means not only less population,
but also an aging population and, therefore,
much less available labor.
Logically, this is all in response to changes
in birth patterns, but there is something
else that can also increase the economic impact
of this decline: the lack of talent retention.
Yes, Germany receives a lot of immigration,
that's for sure.
It’s likely many of you have heard that.
However, there is a problem in this story:
every time a highly skilled German worker
retires, it is not easy to replace him or
her, because as we will see, in Germany there
is no surplus of immigration, but above all
there is no surplus of skilled immigration.
So the question is: Who could say no to the
German giant?
Why are other destinations preferred?
These are the questions we have to find answers
to.
In order to do so, the first thing of all
has to be to understand how we got here.
THE FIRST DEMOGRAPHIC CHIMES
This is not an isolated case, most developed
countries – and also other not so developed
countries such as China and Russia – are
experiencing an accelerated process of demographic
aging.
And, take note, because this process not only
reduces the available labor force, but also
considerably increases public spending:
Think about it, pensions, health care, dependence...
The fact is that Germany understood the problem,
and guess what?
It started to do its homework very early,
no less than half a century ago.
You see, in the 1970s there was a turning
point in Germany, its native population began
to shrink.
That is, the country entered a phase of negative
population growth.
As you can see, since the 1970s the number
of deaths has exceeded the number of births
every year.
To compensate for this, Germany started to
boost immigration.
As you can see, the number of immigrants arriving
each year is generally greater than the native
loss of inhabitants.
This has allowed the country to maintain its
population growth over the years.
Everything depends on the arrival of new immigrants.
And if you look at the graph you will see
how at the beginning of the 21st century the
first alarm was sounded: the arrival of immigrants
plummeted.
At the beginning of the 21st century, almost
all of Europe was growing and growing faster
than Germany.
Germany was far from being the only flower
in an ever-expanding garden of prosperity...
And that, naturally, had consequences.
Competition slowed down the influx of new
labor into German industries.
The question is, what did they do?
The truth is that the Germans took it very,
very seriously.
The government knew how important it was to
attract young talent and maintain demographic
expansion in order to prevent the economy
and the Social Security system from going
into crisis.
So to achieve their goals, in addition to
actively promoting immigration, they also
did things like this, check it out.
(1 January 2005: Germany's first immigration
law goes into effect.
Starting next year, new immigrants will be
entitled to participate in state-funded German
language classes and receive an introduction
to the country's legal system, culture and
history.
The government has earmarked more than 200
million euros for the scheme.
– DW)
The measures worked, and the net number of
immigrants arriving in the country each year
almost tripled.
From 73,000 in 2004, the number increased
to 212,000 in 2008.
And not only that.
By 2016, one of the historical ceilings in
terms of immigrant population was hit: 432,000
non-Germans moved to live in this country.
Of course, Germany is part of the European
Union, so what does that mean?
That the country is subject to free mobility
of people and workers.
Any of the EU members can become a rival country
for labor.
A growing competition that Germany does not
seem to have been able to manage very well.
"DANKE" BUT NO "DANKE")
From 2013 onwards, the influx of immigrants
to Germany started to slow down again.
And even worse, according to OECD reports
the country was becoming less and less attractive
for the arrival of professionals.
Because, and this is important, not all people
are equal.
Logically, from an economic point of view,
qualifications count.
And that is why the OECD issued this warning.
Look at this.
(4 February 2013: Labor migration: Germany
is open to graduates, but immigration is difficult
for medium-skilled workers).
And why did the OECD say this?
Basically because of this.
Pay attention to the data.
("Germany is one of the OECD countries with
the lowest barriers to immigration for highly
skilled workers.
However, the number of immigrant workers from
outside the EU and the European Free Trade
Area (EFTA) it receives is 25,000 per year,
about 0.02% of the population (...) The rate
of skilled immigrant workers received by Australia,
Denmark, Canada and the United Kingdom is
five to ten times higher."
– OECD German Labor Market Report.
2013)
In other words, it was supposedly relatively
easy to emigrate to Germany, but even so,
skilled workers preferred – and still prefer
– other destinations.
Whether because of the language, the standards
or the lifestyle, the fact is that Germany
is not a popular destination.
Of course, that's not the whole story.
A survey conducted by the Swiss-based International
Institute for Management Development found
that German employers' perception of the ease
of recruiting international talent was rather
poor.
In other words, the OECD report did not accurately
reflect the entire reality.
It seems that red tape has been a problem
for a decade now.
In some ways, legislation to attract skilled
immigration dating back to 2005 was becoming
obsolete compared to the incentives on the
table in neighboring countries.
Therefore, between 2018 and 2020, the German
parliament started to make several changes
to the Act.
Changes to make it easier for professionals
from outside the European Union.
For example, it was made easier for immigrants
to arrive without a contract.
However, just then, the pandemic completely
changed the picture.
It brought the arrival of new immigrants to
a screeching halt.
Immigrants of all kinds: skilled and unskilled.
And that, in the long run, only aggravated
the problems.
Since 2013, the Federal Labor Agency itself
has been monitoring what the authorities refer
to as "bottleneck" occupations.
That is, areas of the labor market where job
vacancies cannot be filled by available workers.
In 2020 this situation cooled down, but since
then the trend has returned.
More and more areas of the German economy
are unable to get the skilled workers they
need.
In fact, this indicator is expected to break
records in 2023.
The post-pandemic economic upturn coupled
with the growing demographic aging is pushing
the German labor market into an increasingly
critical context:
While the demand for workers continues to
grow, the number of immigrants arriving each
year has decreased.
Not to mention the number of skilled immigrants.
To give you an idea of what we are talking
about, according to estimates by the German
Economic Institute in Cologne, by mid-2022
there were already 1.5 million vacancies in
this country.
A figure that is expected to grow strongly
over the next few years.
The situation has reached such an extent that
some commercial areas have had to start providing
their services on a reduced basis.
And this is, in fact, what explains news stories
like this:
(25 June 2022: Germany will use temporary
foreign workers to ease staff shortages at
German airports.
Photos of travelers standing in long lines
at security checkpoints at Düsseldorf airport
earlier this week showed the extent of the
shortage.
– Reuters)
In other words, the German economy is in urgent
need of labor of all kinds.
According to estimates by the German Institute
for Labor Market and Employment Research,
at least 400,000 new arrivals are needed each
year to keep the workforce stable.
That's already a problem.
But, VisualPolitik viewers, the free skilled
labor thing...
That's already almost an endangered species
in this country.
According to a survey conducted in December
2022, 7 out of 10 companies are short of skilled
labor.
Not only that, but Germany is now facing another
problem:
It's no longer that few skilled workers are
arriving, it's that many of the ones they
did have are leaving.
In other words, the country is suffering a
brain drain.
And that, that is something that endangers
the formidable industry that fuels Europe's
greatest economic engine.
But...
Let's go back to the question we asked at
the beginning: How on earth is it possible
that there are almost no professionals who
want to live and work in one of the most developed
countries in the world?
Where is the problem?
Well...
Listen up!
THE THREE PILLARS OF THE TALENT DRAIN)
If we try to go straight to the heart of the
matter, we could say that Germany faces three
major problems.
Each of them linked to the others.
For example, first of all...
The stock of human capital from Europe cannot
be expected to last forever!
And why do I say this?
Well, you see, according to official figures,
Serbia has lost 9% of its inhabitants in the
last three decades, North Macedonia 10%, Bosnia
and Herzegovina 24% and Albania 37%.
And something very similar could be said about
Poland and the Baltic republics, among others.
All these countries have lost a large proportion
of their best-educated and most qualified
young people.
And, let’s not forget, Europe is a very
aging continent, so the pool of skilled workers
available for German companies to recruit
is limited.
Basically, the pool of skilled workers is
no longer large enough.
Along these lines, many experts believe that
the "initial effect" of the EU expansions
has already come to an end.
Perhaps Ukraine was the only exception, but
this country has also already suffered a huge
exodus of skilled workers, particularly of
young people.
For this reason, many analysts point out that
the search for talent must look beyond continental
borders.
And do you know what?
This is exactly what led the 2020 reform of
the Skilled Immigration Act to introduce more
facilities for skilled immigrants from third
countries.
For example, university degrees were no longer
required, but vocational training was also
accepted as proof of qualification.
A demand that German employers have been making
for some time.
Why?
Just take a look at this graph.
Of course, this was not the only measure.
Some administrative formalities were also
reduced, but the main stumbling block was
not solved.
Which is none other than this.
The bureaucratic German immigration system
is extremely complex: at least 7 ministries
are involved in the process, without taking
into account second-tier government agencies
and local governments.
To give just one example, the approval of
a qualified professional would involve:
the Federal Ministry of Economic Affairs and
Climate Action,
the Ministry of Labor and Social Affairs,
the Ministry of Education and Research,
the Ministry of Food and Agriculture,
the Ministry of Health,
the Ministry of the Interior and Community
and the Ministry of Economic Cooperation and
Development – so pretty straightforward!
This obviously poses a major disincentive
for German companies.
In 2022, only 17% of the companies surveyed
by the Bertels-mann Foundation recruited skilled
workers from abroad.
And while large companies can hire consultancies
and law firms to speed up the process, SMEs
face an almost insurmountable barrier.
That is, in a way, the 2020 eligibility extension
was a step in the right direction to start
attracting professionals from outside the
European Union, however, it did not prepare
the bureaucracy for such a challenge:
Mobility within the common European block
is much simpler, but when you start incorporating
professionals from other regions, the documentation
and requirements multiply.
It is infinitely more difficult and costly
to incorporate a Thai or Uruguayan worker
than a Polish one.
This is the second problem.
And finally, the third major stumbling block
has to do with a much more complex factor:
the cultural one...
If only because of the language.
In August 2022, the German Federal Employment
Agency turned its attention to this issue.
And do you know what it found?
That most workers who arrive in Germany without
knowing German do not even bother to try to
learn it.
Why?
Because they are thinking of leaving.
Language integration problems, problems in
obtaining permanent residence, housing costs,
cost of living and taxes, problems in reuniting
the family in the country and the clash with
the local culture are the most frequent arguments
given by skilled workers who decide to leave
Germany.
This is something we have already told you
about on VisualEconomik.
To make matters worse, the immigration legislation
clashes with a new type of work that is practically
ignored: freelancers.
Well, these three problems seem to explain
why Germany is not as attractive a country
as it apparently should be.
The question is, is there a way out?
What are German politicians doing?
Well, we are going to take a look at that
right now.
RETAKING THE "JOB APPEAL"
Estimates by the German Ministry of Labor
suggest that, if this situation is not reversed
by 2026, more than 200,000 jobs currently
filled will become vacant.
A situation that could have a very negative
impact on companies, productivity and the
country's economic growth.
Therefore, in October 2022, the issue will
be at the top of the public agenda:
(22 October 2022: How Germany plans to attract
qualified foreigners.
Reforms include the introduction of a so-called
"opportunity card" that will entitle people
to seek work in Germany following a point
system based on language skills, professional
experience and connection to Germany, among
other criteria).
And finally, on 29 March, the Qualified Immigration
Law was amended again,
(29 March 2023: Foreigners with adequate work
experience and education in their home country
will be allowed to work in Germany, even if
those professional qualifications are not
recognized in Germany.
In addition, they will be allowed to work
up to 20 hours per week while looking for
long-term employment.
Finally, it will be possible for persons in
possession of academic degrees or professional
certificates to remain in Germany for up to
one year while seeking employment.
– DW)
Will this new reform work?
Only time will tell.
The question now is:
Would you consider living in Germany?
Would you like to?
How do you think this country can boost the
arrival of new talent?
Leave us your answer in the comments and let's
open a debate.
And now, if you found this video interesting,
don't forget to give it a like and subscribe
to VisualPolitik if you haven't already done
so.
All the best and see you next time.